lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
agarremos un poco de práctica
simplificando unas peliagudas
expresiones exponenciales así que es
buen momento para empezar bueno pues que
te parece si empezamos por tomarnos a
este 10 que va a multiplicar al 9 el
cual está elevado a la potencia de entre
2 t medios y a este exponente le voy a
sumar 2 y bueno todo esto también lo voy
a multiplicar por cinco el cual va a
estar elevado a la potencia 3d y lo que
quiero que hagamos es simplificar esta
expresión tanto como podamos y de
preferencia obtener la forma exponencial
a que multiplica a b éste a su vez
elevado a la potencia de y como siempre
te voy a encargar que pases este vídeo y
que veas si puedes resolver este
ejercicio por tu cuenta usando las
propiedades de los exponentes y bueno
usando también la fuerza de tu
conocimiento
de su conocimiento con las propiedades
de los exponentes así que intenta
resolver este ejercicio por ti mismo
ok pues vamos a resolver este ejercicio
juntos y para eso vamos a ir rompiendo
estas pequeñas piezas poco a poco así
que empecemos con el 10 el 10 lo voy a
dejar exactamente igual por aquí 10 que
multiplican y después tengo esta
expresión de aquí 9 que a su vez está
elevado a la t entre 2 más 2 y esta
parte de aquí la puedo romper usando las
propiedades de los exponentes 9 elevado
a la t más 2 esto de aquí lo puedo
escribir de la siguiente forma si
nosotros recordamos las leyes de los
exponentes entonces esto y voy a poner
aquí las leyes de los exponentes existe
una ley que dice que 9 elevado a la a
más ven esto es exactamente igual que 9
elevado a la anp por 9 elevado a la b
dicho de otra manera si aquí tengo al 9
elevado a la t entre 2 más 2
esto mismo lo puedo transformar como 9
que está elevado
ate entre dos y esto a su vez va a
multiplicar por esta propiedad a nueve
que a su vez está elevado al cuadrado y
ahora vamos a mover esta expresión que
tengo aquí si tengo cinco elevado a la 3
tm bueno esto lo podemos ver por otra
ley de los exponentes como amos recuerda
si tengo am elevado a la b por si y
bueno en este caso a cedía 5 bs de a
tres y se sería t
esto es exactamente lo mismo que
escribir a am elevado a la vez y todo
esto a su vez está elevado a la potencia
c por lo tanto voy a aplicar esta ley de
los exponentes a esta parte de aquí y me
va a quedar por 5 elevado a la tercera
potencia esto a su vez elevado a la
potencia t
y la razón por la cual estoy haciendo
esto es que 5 elevado al cubo es un
número un número fácil de calcular y lo
que estoy intentando hacer es dejar todo
lo que se pueda elevado a nuestra
potencia t para que veas que podemos
simplificar y ahora te puedes dar cuenta
fácilmente que 9 elevado al cuadrado
esto es lo mismo que 81 así que esto es
lo voy a poner como 81 y después tengo
un 5 elevado al cubo lo cual sabemos que
es bueno 5 por 5 25 por 5 es 125 125 en
lugar de esto de aquí y entonces date
cuenta que lo único que tenemos que
trabajar es esta parte de aquí 9 elevado
al late entre 2 y bueno déjame
escribirlo para acá para que sea mucho
más fácil trabajar con el 9 elevado a la
t entre 2 bueno esto lo podemos ver como
9 elevado a la 1
y que multiplica a te estás de acuerdo 9
que a la vez está elevado a la un medio
por tema es lo mismo que 9 elevado a la
medios y ahora si aplicamos esta
propiedad que tengo acá arriba esto lo
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
como un 9 que está elevado a la un medio
primero va este un medio y esto a su vez
va a estar elevado a la potencia de y
ahora date cuenta que 9 elevado a un
medio eso sabemos que es 3 así que esto
me va a quedar como 3 elevado a la
potencia de y por lo tanto ahora sí lo
puede sustituir justo por acá esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3 elevado a la
potencia de y bueno vamos bastante bien
hasta aquí así que es hora de ir
limpiando todo esto que tenemos por acá
primero voy a empezar con este 1010
que está multiplicando y bueno se me
ocurre primero poner el 81 porque es un
valor constante así que lo único que voy
a hacer es voltear a estos 2
voy a poner primero de 81 me va a quedar
81 que a su vez multiplica ahora hay que
multiplicar por este por 3 elevado a la
potencia temp
y después tengo esta parte de aquí no
olvidemos la potencia así que me va a
quedar esto a su vez multiplica a 125
que está elevado a la potencia te vamos
súper bien ahora date cuenta de lo
siguiente 10 por 81 es lo mismo que 810
y después tengo esta parte de aquí y
esta parte de aquí también se puede
simplificar usando las propiedades de
los exponentes
si yo recuerdo otra propiedad de los
exponentes que me dicen y déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla a por ve esto a su
vez está elevado a la potencia temp
esto es exactamente lo mismo que
elevar a am a la potencia t y
multiplicarlo por ver elevado a la
potencia t bueno lo podemos ver de la
otra manera ha elevado date por ver
elevadora temps es exactamente lo mismo
que absorben elevado a la t y justo es
lo que tenemos aquí en este caso tenemos
tres elevado de atn por 125 elevado de
atn
bueno aquí en este caso a vale 3b vale
125 y entonces esto mismo lo podemos
escribir como 3 que multiplica a 125
todo eso a su vez elevado a la potencia
t así que déjame escribirlo aquí esto me
va a quedar como 3 que multiplica a 125
todo esto a su vez elevado a la potencia
de y está genial porque ahora sí puedo
ver todo esto de la siguiente manera
primero voy a tener 810
y multiplicar a 3 por 125
bueno eso lo podemos hacer 3 por 125 es
lo mismo que 375 que multiplica a 375
que a su vez está elevado a la potencia
de de lujo' justo esto queríamos porque
ya con esto tenemos la forma más
simplificada que podemos tener así que
déjenme atrapar justo por acá nuestra
respuesta y si te das cuenta es justo a
lo que queríamos llegar si subimos un
poco en la pantalla justo por acá
date cuenta es lo siguiente queríamos
llegar a la expresión a volver elevado a
la tema y en este caso se nota
claramente que a va a tomar el valor de
810 mientras que ven va a tomar el valor
de 375 así que 375 es nuestro valor de b
pero de cualquier manera espero que este
ejercicio no te parezca complicado
cuando lo veas por primera vez porque si
te centras en aplicar las propiedades de
los exponentes justo por aquí
puedes escribir estos términos en
potencias de ten y que además puedes
seguir rompiendo los con estas
propiedades que tenemos aquí entonces
puedes ver que en pocos pasos llegamos a
este resultado el cual se va a ver mucho
menos peliagudo